good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Thursday a great day
a really just great day Thursdays are so
underrated you know well we
appropriately rate them at the show and
I don't feel like the under rtion falls
on our shoulders I wasn't blaming you I
wasn't blaming you no I feel like the
work that we do in drawing and bringing
light to the days of the week and the
various benefits and Perils of each day
I feel like in work we
appropriately applaud Thursdays as being
just a beautiful day of the week the
various benefits and perils I completely
agree what would you say are the
benefits of Thursday and the perils okay
not me like just not knowing that the
word peril was the opposite of benefit
you truly learned something new here
every day at the toast I don't think
it's a direct antonym but they do have
opposing
meanings I'm just going to like I don't
know what the word peril means Peril is
like a
struggle oh like a tribulation no
serious and immediate danger I really
don't think like that's the right word
honestly what are the serious and
immediate dangers of Thursdays all right
I'll tell you it's easy it's easy to
like get over excited it is you know and
I think a lot of people especially in
New York like Thursday's a big going out
yeah if you're in your going out era if
you're young it's easy to spend it all
on a Thursday night no and like you
don't realize [__] like you still have
to work for like yeah oh and if you're
in college and you're like Thursday it's
the start of the weekend but some people
have class on Fridays right but
sometimes Thursday is the best night of
the week I don't know why it happens
that way yeah no when I was like in my
real true going out era in New York like
Thursday nights were the cool nights
because like the really truly fabulous
cool you know successful rich people
like don't have to get up on Friday well
that's true but also Friday and Saturday
get a little b& bridge and tunnel bridg
and tunnel is there a worse insult I
don't think so is there a worse insult
no but like I think growing up is
realizing like yeah I have to take a
tunnel to my beautiful palacious bucolic
home I know but is it worth being called
bridge and tunnel no they used it in
Gossip Girl a few times and it was
cutting it's I don't know how everyone
got the memo about this insult kind of
like Captain Underpants which is a
reference to our patreon episode
yesterday that and I recorded Captain
Obvious what the hell is Captain
Underpants Captain Underpants is a comic
book yeah yeah
you're showing your age Jack Captain
Obvious we were talking about that
insult on the patreon episode that we
recorded yesterday and it's just like
this biting insult similar to Bridge and
tunnel it cuts Cuts deep bridg and
tunnel is like such a mean thing to say
like oh and it's like it's not even a
creative insult like yeah it's factual I
had to take a bridge to get here no and
it's like so elitist it's like oh you
don't live in the city it's like yeah I
don't live in this [__] hole surrounded
by rats it's so El us it's like okay
cool we like have your insult the
insinuation is that if you don't live in
the city and you have to take a bridge
in tunnel it's merely because you can't
afford it which just really isn't the
case most of the time yeah no there's a
lot of reasons why one might not choose
to live in the city I think these days
bridge and tunnel is less and less of an
insult it's like oh rational thinking
human being but back to the benefits and
Perils of Thursday the benefits I think
are so obvious really for me the benefit
of a Thursday is the Hope
the
haika The Hope exactly like of what's to
come of of having something to look
forward to that by the way getting
through life is just leaning on things
that you're looking forward to and just
like holding on to them for dear life
booing yourself to those to those
moments those trips those vacations
those days off things like that yeah on
a large scale but on a small scale it's
the weekend yeah so I agree it's the
optimism the hope the promise of what's
to come and that's where we're at today
where I'm at is I feel very excited let
me tell you why it's particularly on
this Thursday you know that I like to
consider myself the head of the IT
department here at the toast and my job
over the last couple of years especially
since we went remote is to get our
YouTube video up as quickly as possible
like I know the YouTube girlies wait it
usually comes about an hour after the
podcast goes up I believe today and
we'll we'll test it out today's a day
we're testing it out I believe I have
found a way to get to cut our Youtube
upload time in half that's really
amazing now just a question how come we
didn't know about this sooner so I did
know about it and I learned about it
when I went to the dear media Studio
because I exported using their cameras
and they'd use it differently and I but
I was so nervous about fussing with it
because fin got we've got a good thing
going the YouTube gets up by 1 130 like
that's not the wor quality is
Stellar so I didn't of course I know
there are ways to get it up faster if
you want to put out a [__] video and I
don't so so are you saying it's a ship
video no that's why it took me so long
to figure this out now today will be day
one of figuring it out if you guys don't
like it we won't do it but it should
look exactly the same it should look the
same it's the same specs as like I was
actually sending to you it's it's the
same and I'm also excited because
tomorrow is the day that like 80% of my
furniture gets delivered I got most of
the stuff that I got for my new
apartment from Craton barrel and
delivery one of three is coming tomorrow
and most of it is coming
so that means you know rugs coffee table
cenza night stce probably my favorite
thing that I got is my night stce I'm
just so excited it's very exciting I'm
doing another Furniture wave of
furniture like my house isn't totally
done and now I was like itching to do
more and then I just got super busy but
now like there are things that I need in
my daily life so I'm working with best
again like I need new rugs I need to
finish up some places move them a little
barren excuse me just a little empty and
that's I feel like the lack of
rugs by the way stop I love your house
Jackie could I spend more time at your
house you've never even been to my house
okay yes I have I was at your house more
recently than you were at mine I've
literally spent probably 6 months
cumulatively at your home you actually
haven't been here in a very long time oh
sorry that you moved to New York for 6
months what was I supposed to do go lay
in your house no I mean I've been back
here now for 5
months oh my God the expect the
entitlement expect the way I just became
insulted about something so your defense
mechanism is to find an insult in
something that I'm saying oh my God
you're being crazy Jackie do you not
agree that your house is just a little
Baron you have no rugs I have rugs I'm
getting a new rug okay you know what I'm
sorry I'm sorry a little Baron is a
crazy thing to say about a warm loving
home that's been nothing but open and
welcoming to you
okay she's eating her words and she
doesn't know how to just
say I'm not sorry so I'm just shutting
up cuz I do I think your house is a
little Barren and you just said you need
more [__] like please please I
can't by the way my house is Barren too
it's not a bad thing it is a bad thing
and your house is
not way even though it's not done and
perfect yet it's a lovely home that you
have oh my God I I can't talk to you I
can't talk to you now if you're going to
be slinging insults oh my God I feel
like all I'm always talk about is like
how your house is so great I love your
house I can't spend enough time there I
made one little [__] comment and now
I'm the villain I and by the way it
wasn't even hurtful it's factual your
house is a little Barren you're not done
yet no it's not you're not oh my God
okay so just I'm not at 100% of
purchases that doesn't mean a little
Baron and keep repeating
it okay
okay I think we should change the
subject I think so
too back to the benefits and Perils of
it being Thursday it's Thursday we've
got a great show nothing special you
know like no you know quirky segments
that's it's Thursday but we're sandwich
between two days with quirky segments
today is just going to be a good
oldfashioned chat Fest a girly girl
chitchat if you will yeah we have good
stories solid again I would say similar
to yesterday in terms of tone and tenor
tone and tenor and that's all any Recaps
I know you're still watching the crowns
so excited for you to finish that we can
get into it but we actually have Royal
news today so if you have any additional
thoughts we'll put it in the Royal news
I don't really have any additional
thoughts I only watched one episode I'm
not like having this Renaissance that
you are having with it like I actually
find it like somewhat difficult to get
through oh I'm just like waiting for the
episodes to be over what's the consensus
from people about how this season is I I
heard people loved it I think people
just love the show and they really Ted
it up nice in a bow MH but I just find
it like a little first of all boring
second of all like cringe and I don't
know I'm just like not loving it what's
cringe up to the part with by the way
William William's like cringe what did
he do he just had that Outburst in the
library oh
cringe
yeah that wasn't great and I wonder if
that really happened because it's kind
of central to Kate and Williams
storyline yeah no and then it's like
Kate like doesn't want to date the king
of England but her mom is making her
like I can't I'm sure she wanted to
please who wouldn't yeah no I think she
like had a crush on him as a girl I
actually thought the way that they dealt
with all that that cuz it's true that
like it's not an accident that they met
and as much as her mother could like
socially engineer it she did but not in
an aerious way you know what I mean yeah
but also it would be unrealistic for any
girl her age
who any girl her age to not have had
everyone everyone did not a big crush on
him right right but when her mom was
like he just needs a nice normal girl
like it wasn't like she didn't have bad
intentions even though like
that sort of social engineering looks
like social climing yeah it it there is
that element but it's not in a
nefarious user way like yeah she wants
the best for both of them it's kind of
sweet and I thought that they handled it
really well it's like okay there is this
backstory it's not all as serendipitous
as it looks like she literally followed
him to all of these programs yeah but
it's still cute and it can still be cute
I also didn't think that Kate was cast
amazingly she does start to look more
and more like Kate but at first I'm like
who I didn't know we were supposed to be
watching Kate I was like oh well there's
two different
actresses like I'm pretty sure there was
that one scene where she runs into
William and Diana I'm not talking about
that okay and then it turns into the
actress who plays Kaden at first I
thought she wasn't the right casting
either but then she really grew on me
the actress to the point where like
they're kind of
indistinguishable oh wow yeah so just
wait just wait for Kate um so I didn't
watch a lot of TV I went to bed super
early you know battling this little
tickle in my throat I'm sure you guys
can hear it and it's getting worse so I
needed like lots and lots of sleep and
had this crazy dream about me Theo Ben
and Ariel
chartis a fellow C lover yeah we were
like running around town cuz I lost my
bag and everyone was helping me and then
turns out Ben had it this cab driver was
yelling at me classic classic I mean he
literally has your bag right now oh my
God so true how's he doing out there on
the west coast Best Coast good he took
another trip this time he went to
Blooming dalls he needed some more
clothing because he was invited to play
basketball with some you know some boys
and he needed basketball
shorts and I think it all went well
great I think it all went well great and
then he got I was FaceTiming with him
yesterday the last time I was in LA I've
been dreaming about this piece of food
all the Jewish girlies told me like you
have to go try Lenny's Cita it's like a
great Mexican restaurant but they
created like a Crunch Wrap Supreme
that's totally Co sure when I I don't
even think I would like a crunch trap
Supreme it's like not what I crave you
crun trap Supreme yes but you know I got
it I tried it out this [__] was so
[__] good it was enormous like I
swear to God I licked every last grain
of rice off my fingers so good I've been
thinking about it recently and when Ben
was going to La I'm like you have to go
get it so he facetimed me and ate it and
it was like honestly it was healing did
he like it as much as you did loved he
should try and remake it at
home oh oh my God I love that idea yeah
you don't take advantage of Ben's
culinary skills enough at all actually
and you just have it make you like
Minute Rice in the microwave no but he's
a chef he could look at that and remake
it that's what he
does I absolutely love that idea
brilliant Beyond brilliant idea yeah I'm
really excited for you oh my God I can't
wait for Ben to come
home put him to work totally and then he
can Master it and he can come make it
forever everyone yeah yeah yeah when we
come to your beautiful and full home he
can make it for everyone oh my God the
kids would love it I love so much fun so
much fun so much fun in your beautiful
full home and
then why you want to go back
there why you want to go back there I'm
trying to correct it I'm trying to
correct
it
I think without further Ado we should
get into the stories yes mostly because
I'm really excited and lowkey proud of
our first sponsor oo exciting without
further ad Ado here are the fast five
stories that are brought to you by our
prideful sponsor so I was talking about
this company on the patreon the other
day
rbody
so row provides access to the most
popular weight loss shots on the market
so row I'm sure heard of this company I
have heard of them too I've heard people
having amazing experiences the Rob body
program pairs a weekly shot with healthy
lifestyle changes so you can lose 15 to
20% of your weight in a year on average
and actually keep it off over 200,000
people have already chosen roow to help
them lose weight rbody program members
have support throughout the entire
process their Partners handle all the
insurance paperwork to get the
medication covered if eligible for
medication patients will have access to
their provider on demand for any
questions I think a lot of people are
really intrigued by these medications
and do not not know where to start and
row I feel like is kind of like killing
it out here for everyone before being
prescribed the medication you'll have to
complete an online medical visit a lab
test and you'll actually have to qualify
for the medication based on BMI lab
results medical history and at the
discretion of a row Affiliated
healthcare provider so you know they're
really taking care of it from beginning
to end they're going to help you try and
get it covered by insurance I love this
company I love obviously I've spoken
really publicly about my experience with
weight loss medication it's really been
fabulous for me so you can sign up from
the comfort of your own home average
weight loss is 15 to 20% any year with
healthy lifestyle changes BMI and other
eligibility criteria apply go to
r.co toast sign up today and you'll pay
just $99 for your first month and $145 a
month after that medication costs are
separate that's
r.co toast today's episode is also
brought to you by poppy it's no secret
that soda has become a dirty word too
sugary too syrupy and we don't blame you
for wanting to leave it in the past but
that era of soda is officially over it's
time to SI a soda that you love and that
loves you right back so let us put you
on to our favorite one poppy with clean
ingredients 5 grams of sugar or less and
25 calories or less it has all the soda
flavor without any of the typical soda
baggage um cutting out soda has been
like something I've been very very very
slowly doing now I haven't cut it
completely from my life because I have
to be reasonable but there was a point
where I was having like three or four a
day and that's not good I was definitely
like you know addicted poppy is a great
thing to lean on if you're trying to cut
out soda if you're just trying to drink
less soda it's so good it's such like a
fun beverage you like put it in a glass
with ice all the girls on Tik Tok are
always making like these mocktails with
it it's so good they come in so many
good flavors and if you're really like
addicted to
certain sodas they have flavors that
taste just like it so if you're like a
Dr Pepper girl their doc po pop flavor
tastes just like it their Cola flavor
tastes a lot like Coke they also have
fresh fruit flavors like strawberry
lemon cherry limeade orange grape they
are bursting with the juiciest flavors
you ever tasted so you can shop poppy on
Amazon and you can get 15% off with code
toast 15 off and of course you can get
it in retailers Nationwide that's poppy
p o PPI and you can shop it on Amazon
and get 15% off with our code which is
toast5 off that's T
S15
FF thank you our first story is that Kim
Kardashian is relaunching makeup skin by
Kim makeup is a collection of lip liners
lipsticks and an eye shadow shadow
palette that are out on January 26th so
Kim previously
had K KW Beauty and then it was taken
off the market reformulating and then
she got divorced so it's like is it
still going to be kkw and now she's
coming back with her makeup Under the
Skin umbrella which is herend high-end
skincare company so this will be skin by
Kim makeup I think this is great for a
multitude of reasons one people really
like there was a cult following for a
lot of her products specifically her lip
products like her line ERS so her
bringing it back people really wanted
and her first products being lip
products is really really smart I also
think this is going to give skin kind of
like the Boost it needed skin made like
some waves when it first launched it was
exciting and I feel like seriously I
can't imagine more than five people
place in order a day like I just feel
like it really fell off the face of the
planet so I think her makeup being under
there will boost the whole company give
it like a whole fresh lift yeah
and and I like the idea because when I
read the the brand like uh the makeup
description it's like a skin care first
Makeup Company and I think that's like a
new trend where it's like we're not
putting harsh chemicals it's clean it's
good for your skin it's Foundation
that's also skin care so it's very
trendy and I actually think this is like
kind of brilliant no I think the way
that it's branded and like being under
the skin umbrella like saves skin and
brings back Kim makeup under a new name
that's not really new you don't have to
introduce a new brand I think it's all
pretty oh and then it fixes the problem
of kkw of course yeah so I think it's
very smart and Kim makeup makes a lot of
sense it always has made sense more so
even than high in skincare yes I think a
lot of people um like Quake over the
fact that they both Kylie and Kim like
have major makeup companies like is that
not considered you know weird or we're
competitive but they're both now owned
like 50% each by the same conglomerate
Cody
and I just don't really feel like they
care no I think when they first came out
at the similar times when Kim like
launched a makeup company right after
kyes was so successful that was the time
when it was like oh will this be weird
and then they moved forward and it
wasn't weird and if you're really into
makeup like you can see that there are
Stark differences between the Vibes of
both Brands and people buy so much
makeup there it's such a huge market and
they're two of the biggest faces in
Beauty soble it's not
that crazy when you think about it no
you're totally right and especially like
in The Vibes being so different I feel
like Kylie's is very much like a
colourpop like a little wacky very like
fun young bright bold colors type of
makeup and Kim especially with this new
launch it's very nude like the makeup
palette is completely nude the lips are
all nude that's so her she's like bronze
Contour Brown Queen like brown lip liner
everything um and I do feel like that's
very much like where the beauty
community and like the beauty trends are
going is more of the Kim Direction
sometimes Kylie's products do feel a
little outdated but I know she just
launched a foundation yesterday and she
had recently done a concealer so I do
feel like she's moving out of that like
colourpop 2016 like Rave girl Vibe
makeup and more towards like a clean
girl dewy aesthetic yeah she definitely
is and I also when I think of their
brands I think of Kylie's makeup is like
for a younger girl and Kim's like is a
more mature look so I think when you get
into the weeds there are differences but
of course like from the zooming out it's
like they're the same looking person and
they have makeup lines at a glance yeah
but it's not like that and I think
there's enough of the pie to go around I
do also think Kik aw fragrances will be
rolled into this as well I think she
said that in her
video um which doesn't make as much
sense no but her fragrances also had
like a crazy cult following so she like
she's got bring it back you know she's a
businesswoman yeah and she's got to
bring back the body
foundations she died that's my favorite
product of hers wow by the way the
cultural impact those products had like
remember when she was showing MJ's hands
that was like and the brush like that
was the craziest
time was it the craziest time yes yes
like I remember where I was when it
happened you know yeah even though I
actually didn't really end up liking the
product it got all over my clothing oh I
love it you you can't like wear it on
underneath clothes not that you would
you wear it when your skin is showing
but it's a game changer like for someone
if you have like veiny skin whatever
your everyone has their own things but
it like it's totally like an airbrush
effect just getting it off was kind of
annoying but it was worth it because you
had such a great look she's really had
so many like iterations of her Brands MH
and it does feel like she's like
downsizing a little bit in the sense
that she doesn't need five different
companies for different beauty products
like kkw fragrance kkw beauty skin skims
like so many different now it's like
really she has skims and skick in yeah
and I think eventually maybe in like
five years skin by Kim Beauty especially
if the Kim Beauty part takes off like it
could morph into just Kim Beauty for
everything yeah and maybe they scale
back some of the skin care and beef up
cuz Kim Beauty could also Encompass
fragrance yes yes and that's just a nice
name it's interesting none of the girls
have really ever done hair they had
Kardashian hair I know we have Olivia
still uses their hairbrush Olivia has a
hairbrush that's literally from the 19th
century she refuses to change it and
it's kkw hair and we growing up we all
like shared a bottle of hairspray in our
bathroom and it was this huge bottle of
KK no Kash hair hair yeah that was when
they just did licensing deals that Shir
was good by the way it was good but but
I'm surprised none of them even though
like hair care is not huge and I guess
they're like really close with Jen Atkin
who does whey and wey like kills it I
mean Mario has makeup oh I guess yeah
everyone has something it is it is
surprising that they don't do more hair
care even just like a hairspray a lot of
people Ultra clutch
hairspray Ultra clutch hairspray wo
that's me he's Cy Collins
um
what was I going to say you're were
saying a lot of
people are pointing out like that a lot
of Kim's new makeup products in terms of
just like color story are really similar
to some of Mario's products well that
makes perfect sense to me because he
does her makeup and they like the same
thing yeah like she popularized the look
that he created right so it would be
weird if their makeup products weren't
similar yeah and Mario like does really
well yeah it would be in
congruous has Kim ever sold her makeup
products in store cuz Kylie's in Ulta
but neither of them are in Sephora was
kkw in Ulta yeah I'm getting yes I'm
sure it'll be back there again yeah so
very exciting for the beauty Community I
actually need to re I need to like buy
more lipsticks in general I feel like
I've lost all of mine so true and I
don't know I'm wearing like an old Kylie
today but the oldies are the best this
is like angel I'm wearing the Kylie that
you left here that is quite literally my
favorite product I have a problem where
like if I put on lipstick it's gone in a
minute it's gone what color is that this
you're going to have to scrub off with a
Brill pad I believe it's posie oh That's
posie a classic I feel like it's not
posie it's not hold on Angel is posy k
posie k is a is a gorgeous pink
everybody in the words of Taylor Swift
like everybody moved
on I stayed there everybody moved on
from like these matte liquid lipsticks
it's like so 2018 when we were wearing
chokers when you like talk for a living
and you need to be on camera for a full
hour and you need your lipstick not to
move I got home yesterday I did a
workout I went to get BOTOX at T gy I
came back this [__] was still on no I
know I'm wearing a matte liquid lip too
I'm wearing angel and I love this color
is from an old holiday collection and
then she made it mainstream but now she
changed all her colors like none of the
classics are there but what's so funny
is you always like clown on K
Cosmetics you're like it's old and
trendy and she hasn't done anything
great in a while and every time I bring
a product to the studio you steal it the
butter the bomb I just want to say I
didn't you left these here no no but
okay you make it your own you could
leave I could leave something there and
be like oh that crap Jackie left but
instead I'm never getting him
back take them take them what color is
that bomb that's the best
color Kylie of course I was
like Kylie by Kylie 808
Kylie so yeah
I I got to get some more lipsticks cuz I
leave them all there yeah no I'm kind of
in my lip liner and like a bomb era
that's like what all the kids on Tik Tok
are
doing so I'm just like young you know
I'm trendy like that extremely Kim also
posted a video of her offices that had
people buzzing because she made like a
viral trendy video showing what she has
in her office which is like a 3D mold of
her plane and her brain she has a
tanning bed okay let's talk about the
tanning bed that really shocked me me
too the this the the video for those who
like aren't acclimated with Tik Tok
culture is this trend where you're like
it started being like I'm a girl of
course I'm going to have two dinners
like things that are like girly and then
people started changing like me and Ben
did one like we're married of course
we're going to blah blah blah and so
hers was I'm a Kardashian of course I
have a tanning bed in my office I'm a
Kardashian of course I have a a model of
my brain in my plane on my desk and it
just was a way for her to like show off
all the kind of crazy things that she
has in her office yeah and just create
Buzz for her office where her company
skinn by Kim Beauty resides what was
more shock not more shocking the tanning
bed was the most shocking but then like
moved on and apparently it's good for
psoriasis treatment yeah because a lot
of people were like no [__] way like
that's actual like '90s [__] but she is
obsessed with being taned I know but
like we see her with spray tans all the
time I feel like she's mastered the
spray
yeah I don't honestly like I don't know
I don't know but the having the custom
Rick
Owens Furniture everything walls
everything like how expensive is that
like isn't this a
business but like Kim is so rich like
like that's nothing for them I guess and
I'm sure maybe he even just like did it
for fun and for free for that video that
we're all now talking about Rick Owens
and now it's just like in the background
of everything yeah what else I love she
has a mold of her Kim air airplane a
model excuse me and also a model of her
brain she had like the big TV screens
with all her campaigns oh
yeah she had you know a hallway with
every um framed magazine cover she's
ever done yeah and then it ended with of
course I'm going to I'm Kim Kardashian
of course I'm going to launch 15 lip
liners all different shades of nude so
you know bringing it back selling
product I imagine the launch will go or
if it went well yeah I no it's it hasn't
gone yet January
26 love I think it'll go well too yeah
are you ready for our next story
exciting Sports Entertainment News
senen the Super Bowl pregame performers
have been announced pregame as in star
spangle Banner America the Beautiful and
lift every voice and sing no [__] way
wait by the way is is it Usher halftime
yes a sure half time we know okay okay
national anthem will be sung by Rea
McIntyre no I love wait by the way I
like lowkey like never heard Reba saying
know I'm I don't love it but I'm but I
hope it's good and I'm open to changing
my tune but like that's not like the
name on everybody's lips when it comes
to who should sing the national anthem
honestly um it's also really hard to
beat what Chris Stapleton just did like
that's the blueprint now that's the B
are oh no I feel like there's so many I
I'm like I I hope she does amazing and
that I'm wrong I'm not even saying
anything just that like I agreed I don't
know what her singing voice really
sounds like and I I think she has like a
lovely country twang voice but like you
need to have like power house blown away
I want tears in my eyes Goosebumps on my
skin this is a song for like the
Jennifer Hudsons of the world people
with huge voices yeah it's such a hard
song to sing yeah so we'll interesting
we'll see then America the Beautiful
Will Be Sung by post
Malone what
yeah okay and lift every voice and sing
will be sung by Andre
day okay see that's a perfect casting
Andre day thank you so much like that's
obviously someone understanding the
assignment her voice is amazing amazing
she would be amazing on the national
anthem you know who we need to sing the
national anthem who Cynthia arivo I feel
like she has I feel like she actually
has too but like not at the Super Bowl
let me Google it like at it like a
important sports game but not the Super
Bowl you know yes I feel like it
actually could have been the Super Bowl
though I feel like I would remember
that oh my God first link Cynthia rivo
messed up USA Anthem first link Cynthia
rivo apologizes after forgetting the
words to the US national anthem I just
want to say I don't think that's like an
offense worth apologizing for like you
made a mistake it's fine like no I think
it's worth apologizing you had one job
no I mean like it's it's not I'm saying
it's not like a thing you do with bad
intentions like no oh no but you can
make a mistake without being bad
intentioned I feel like that's what a
lot of mistakes are yeah that's what a
mistake is yeah still does doesn't mean
that you don't have to apologize like
depends what it is but
like or you just go down to someone who
messed up the national anthem and didn't
give a hoot by the way who hasn't
messed up the national anthem Chris
houon you yeah when in Houston Lady Gaga
pink but who has Fergie Fergie wait
Melissa Gorga Christina Aguilera has I
believe Jessica Simpson has yeah it
happens it's not like we don't need to
go to jail but just be like oops
sorry I think she could still maybe
maybe like that being on her record is
why they haven't chosen her yeah
and that would make sense it's the
biggest stage another chance it's the
biggest stage for the anthem but also a
lot of Arenas like on the Jumbotron put
the lyrics up for everyone no I know
that's why and it's like if you're
struggling to remember if you know that
maybe you don't know that like down pat
which is understandable and some of the
words are like conf like repetitive and
it's like wait what did they say there
are we just like kind of muscle memory
sing it but it's like what's the actual
word you could get a like a prompter
yeah of course but it's also like the
nerves yeah Hannah Montana messed it up
right did she there was an episode where
she messed it up I think at a basketball
game or something yeah that's it's
just not great not like the biggest
worst thing you could
do but you know a lot of people want to
hear a great national
anthem this lineup is unique it is
unique I feel like it's always
underwhelming when we now who it is you
know what I mean yeah it's never like
Banger Banger Banger people who would
just like be amazing no questions asked
it's also hard to get three big stars CU
like the big one the headliner is the
national anthem and if you're a mega
star and they're not offering you that
like you're not going to do one of the
two losery songs I don't know I feel
like I don't even need a big star cuz
sometimes the big stars don't have the
best voices they're just like the best
performers I just want a gorgeous voice
on the ones and twos you know who hasn't
done it who I feel like could do like a
really interesting
version
Miley yeah she has like a Rockery voice
and she can really like sing big yeah
she can sing big but the thing is I
don't want an interesting version
generally speaking but Chris stapleton's
wasn't traditional no it wasn't right
and it was it brought tears to my eyes
yeah I'm like if you're going to do an
interesting version it's got to be like
Chris steton or or else it's Fergie no
there the thing is you're going to do an
interesting version and you're either
going to be a Fergie or Chris Teton
there's really no in between so you have
to be really confident I agre that Miley
could do an interesting version that
would be beautiful yeah
yeah I'm so excited for the Super Bowl
we're going to be together right yeah
and I'm so excited party on my place
yeah what are you making maybe Ben can
make us our crunch trap Supreme for sure
last year I made nachos that were so
good from the Magnolia table recipe book
oh I I never knew I like nachos so much
I the thing is I don't really [__] with
nachos no there's nothing not to like
Claudia it's taco meat actually on top
of chips that's it oh okay and there's
like cheese and olives I don't like
olives so I don't use them there is
cheese and and but I can you like cheese
what's wrong chees cheese is fine but
Sal I not a lot of cheese actually like
when I was in Mexico tinks my sister in
Christ was eating
nachos and I went to tast it it was like
it was disgusting like so much cheese no
I won't use so much and Joanna she's got
the ratio down just trust the process
law okay so you're going to make oh this
is such a fun conversation you're going
to make
nachos Ben's going to make a crunch trap
Supreme okay oh my God you know we
actually really should do and patreon it
CH chili well yes but have you seen like
people that do chili like on their
Island they like lay um like a Chili
board yeah but it takes up their whole
Island and they lay tin foil down they
cover their entire Island in tin foil
uhhuh and they like put chips chili like
veggies guac they like make like a whole
like a big board it's kind of like
nachos too but it's chil yeah oh maybe
they do nachos actually yeah [__] I
don't like
nachos I just told you you're going to
like I'm going to make tury style nachos
okay I also think we should make like
mini girl
cheeses okay you don't love that no like
cute why Mini
because like I don't want to eat a whole
grilled cheese and I'll get full and I
won't be able to eat all the other
things you're making yeah Super Bowl
food is kind of hard cuz it's like you
make the the nachos and you've got the
chips and guaca and all these things but
it's like okay but what's for
dinner all of it like you're not going
to make like a brisket no it's like some
people then also order pizza what about
like brisket sliders yum cuz our brisket
was so good it was good but I do think
we'll be full and honestly
chili like chili is the name on
everybody's lips for for the Super Bowl
and it could be an appetizer it could be
a dip it can be a main course maybe I
should like have go on a chili fast so I
could be like really excited for the
chili at the Super Bowl totally and
maybe some cornbread okay wait and who
is going to make the chili you were bed
I am okay because the you haven't had my
chili we just had Ben's Chili Ben is
making the crunch WAP Supremes okay so
I'm goingon to make the chili love yeah
you know what I'm gonna do instead of
having been now that I've like spoken
about this kosher restaurant in La that
everyone should go to it's so good maybe
they could just like freeze dry some and
send them to me so I can like have them
in my house or maybe they could like go
on gold belly yes exactly but I think
Ben could do a good job no for sure but
it'll never be the same and I I really I
want that one yeah so I would like 10
crunch WP supremed like freed stride and
sent to my home okay are you ready for
our next story what number three oh wow
yeah we're moving slow we are moving
slow but these last three are quick
quickies and I have nowhere to be and
our video is going to upload so [__]
fast oh and by the way I believe because
of this new way we now have more time on
our
cards I think we might have like two two
and a half hours instead of an hour 35
oh no but I think an hour 35 is like I
agree it's it was the limit for a reason
I know I agree and it's not like it's a
weekly like in a day by the way if we
did weekly episodes I think our episodes
would be 3
hours yeah maybe it would it would still
be fast five but it would be Hardy
stories but I don't think we could just
do five stories like we'd have to do
like the fast 50 the fast 15 the fast
15 and then we should break it up five a
day
right can I just say like how annoyed I
am to not have a voice it's like really
pissing me off it's not as bad as it was
oh you think it's getting better 100% I
didn't even notice it oh oh okay also I
got Botox yesterday I know don't rub it
in some of us are rankly but I did
something that I think you'd be proud of
because I've been talking to you you're
lip filler I didn't get lip filler I've
been talking to you a lot in private
about how like with my weight loss like
I have a new smile and it's pissing me
off it's so ugly it's so gummy I look
like a like a Disney adult like with big
gums like and I don't like it that was
mean I'm sorry that was mean
so what did you do so I asked Dr gey
what I should do and she was like before
we do anything extreme let's just try
this she and by the way so [__]
painful I almost I mean everything is
painful for you no no no this was next
level and she told me it was going to be
pain what was it just a little bit of
boto like right under my nostril why oh
to that your lipes curl it will relax my
lip when I smile and my lip won't you
know fold in on itself smile she was
also like it's possible like that your
face is different like you don't really
know how to smile anymore because they
used to smile so hard I don't know why
no but maybe like you were smiling
really hard but it kind of like looked
normal
cuz there was
like the structure of your face was
different now when you smile so hard
it's like it's just a lot of teeth okay
um now sound off in the comments which
smile do you like best cuz I've been
working through it show us your smile
right now even though the botex probably
hasn't taken effect yeah no no no okay
ready this is the one I think I'm going
to go with but when it's like when when
you have to think about your smile and
not just do it yeah just go so unnatural
okay that's classic
tury okay but sometimes I go a little
too hard this is number two that's okay
that's like if you're taking a picture
where you genuinely are feeling that way
but you you should never be putting on
that smile okay and then sometimes I do
this
like a classic so I think number one but
sound off in the comments one two or
three yeah but we also have to wait for
the nostril talk to kick in well yeah
but this is like the worst it's going to
be so we can only get better yeah but
all of those Smiles looked good but I
know the smile you're talking about like
I know that there is a problem this is
literally when a date with Tad Hamilton
when she has like seven Smiles oh yeah
but those are all like natural yeah yeah
and know she doesn't have the problems
that I have we all have three smiles
like one which is
classic two which is OV excited
sometimes it calls for it
or and then three Mary Kate and
Ashley I love year number one it was
gorgeous do it
again so cute and honestly like I love
smiling I'm not a miserable [__] like I
smile all the time because I'm filled
with joy and I bring joy to others and
I'm hysterical and I'm just always
laughing so this is like a big problem
for me it's not like I'm if I was
miserable and depressed like my smile
changing like wouldn't matter because
I'm never smiling I smile at least 100
times a
day but you're not worried about your
IRL smile like when you smile when tury
Smiles in and
down smil when you smile just in life
like it's a beautiful warm thing no it's
not like it's gotten ugly no the issue
is your picture smile we're working on
your picture smile right all of them I
think your everyday in conversation you
know not captured smile your smile and
motion is
beautiful did we ever get to the third
story like we started we started talking
about how we were going slow you became
determined to like elongate the episode
oh that's so funny I really didn't so
natural no you could see the wheels
natur you could see the wheels like
turning and and this is how we ended up
talking about when tury smile and aren't
you glad yeah okay our next story we
have to get to because it's what
everyone's buzzing about cuz people are
saying that Jacob ol Lordi and Olivia
Jade have broken up for the second time
and I don't know why everyone like now
we all just believe US Weekly like I
don't know if this is true or not but
I'm certainly not going to believe it
wholeheartedly yes I think people just
wanted it to be true because they think
they should be dating Jacob aord and
don't get me wrong I think I should be
dating Jacob all but like if it can't be
me like it absolutely should be Olivia
Jade agreed I don't want this feech here
but a source did tell Us Weekly that
they broke up again allegedly for the
second time agreed that US Weekly source
is thin and everyone's kind of running
with it which is weird but then I also
saw that she unfollowed him on Instagram
I didn't check her following but there's
a chance she never followed him to begin
with I'm fairly certain she never
followed him to begin with and like the
way that rumors get started off of that
when most of the time people don't
follow their significant others like
unless they're literally married like
because it makes it such a big deal when
they break up and then they unfollow
most of the time they like Taylor Swift
didn't even follow Joe aln they were
together for six years like right and
I'm sure she has a Fina where she does
her
actual stuff stuff and this is like her
public facing so it's not like they were
ever super public did they ever walk a
red carpet together no no so it's it
it's not crazy every photo we've ever
seen of them has been taken against
their will yeah like you by Paparazzi
spotted so anyways I'm hoping this isn't
true if it is true I don't think it is
like I really don't cuz you're a friend
of OJ I but sorry I have no proof like I
don't know anything but you don't have
info I have media literacy and I don't
just like believe things I see on US
Weekly and nowhere else like if there is
a source why isn't the source going to
like Vogue you know yeah well or like e
page six daily
mail it doesn't make sense yeah and I'm
hoping it's not true so I'm going to be
in denial unless I have a reason not to
be but this is thin agreed and I think
like we're not even in denial
I think we're just like thinking
critically yeah no but if it was a
couple that like I didn't feel strongly
about I wouldn't be like fighting
against it so hard but by the way they
have like lowkey been together for a
really long time like they were first
spotted together in
yeah and I know that article says that
they had broken up at one point and
gotten back together we don't know that
to be true they could have just been
together this whole time
right so I just I love every reminder
that they are together you know and
they're so not in our faces at all I
wish they would be more and you know for
me they remind me so much of fourth Wing
like they are Zaden and violet oh my God
wait wait even though I'm pretty sure
Zaden is black oh yes but I know you
mean like huge man tiny girl yeah and
she actually does give Violet energy a
lot yeah no I agree like when I was
reading the book and they would talk
about like their extreme height
difference it reminded me of those
pictures of Jacob and Olivia no love so
I'm rooting for them but that's this is
what sources are saying I don't believe
the sources the sources can grab a spoon
totally are you ready for our next story
no no is it the next story that's
brought to you by Jenny Kane
t Okay so support for today's show comes
from Jenny Kane home very appropriate
for me because I got Jenny Kane couches
and that's like a was like a goal of
mine Jenny Kane I feel like every time
we do an ad all we say is like she is
Chic if you if I could give an aesthetic
it would be like a mix of Coastal Grand
a mix of you know neutral Nancy Myers
and that is Jenny Kane it's like very
Coastal it's very beachy she covers a
bunch of different like Styles but I
love Jenny Kane home it's a California
brand through and through the interior
pieces are Classics it's clean it's
effortless it's totally refined from
luxurious bedroom Linens iconic
Furniture cozy pillows and throws Jenny
Kane home is here to help you live your
best year yet and for a limited time our
list ERS get 15% off their first order
go to Jenny kane.com use the code toast
to get 15% off that's a really good
discount for Jenny Kane it is the
ultimate destination for elevated Home
Essentials with winter weather on its
way you need cozy Tings in your home
whether it's you know a cold front in
Florida or a blizzard in New York we
need blankets we need slippers we need
candles we need throw pillows we need
Jenny Kane home is what we need and I
got yeah I got a couch the harbor sofa
I'm obsessed it's like linen it's so
would be in an ny Myers movie so also
this year if you're looking I know
Jackie's like really into upping her
tabletop game with like you know cute
TCAP yes Jenny Kane is the place to be
they have a collection of Classics that
make it so easy it's durable their
Pacific dinner wear collection it's
perfect for everyday use so find the
perfect home pieces at Jenny kane.com
our listeners are getting 15% off your
first order when you use C toasta
checkout that's 15% off your first order
at
jni k y ne.com promo code toast today's
episode is also brought to you by Blue
Nile jewelry we say this every year but
we're feeling really good about this
year in particular you know it was we're
coming off the year of yes we're coming
off the year of Tesla Jackie and I both
just finished our resolutions like
actually to completion yes so it feels
like a lot of fun surprises are in store
for us this year and the number one way
to guarantee that is by treating
yourself to a little something something
from Blue nile.com so Blue Nile offers
thousands of independently graded
diamonds and fine jewelry at prices
significantly below traditional retail
so whether you're looking for a bit of
New Year's Sparkle for yourself or a
gift for someone special like I don't
know maybe the co-host in your life Blue
Nile offers peace of mind with every
purchase with some of the highest
quality standards in the industry if you
have questions about their pieces blue
Nile's jewelry experts are on hand 247
via phone or chat from technical
questions to budget suggestions they're
here to help you find a gift that you
can feel great about so whether you're
buying a gift for someone in your life
or like you have a birthday coming up
and you need like to send your boyfriend
some suggestions to send some links from
Blue nle it's a really reputable company
I have a gorgeous pair of like hoops
from Blue Nile they wear so well they
don't change my skin different colors
they're made really really well um and
they're you know more reasonably priced
than they would be if I had bought them
somewhere else so you can experience the
ease and convenience of shopping Blue
Nile today at Blue Nile the original
online Jeweler go to Blue nile.com to
find the perfect piece today that's blue
n i l e.com to find the perfect piece
today thank you
la yeah welcome our next story a little
more Farm news because Ian summerer is
talking about having no regrets about
ditching Hollywood for the farm life
with his wife Nikki Reid oh my God the
fact that these two are married like I
always forget I know and they're super
married she um and they're both vampires
they're both vampires now they're both
Farmers they have two children she had a
home birth and they live on a farm now
and I feel like a lot of people don't
know that okay so here's the thing like
it's just outside of La so he didn't
like really leave Hollywood
but if you look at the pics of their
life like it's it's a farm no and I know
that there's like hardcore Farmland in
the state of California but like of
course no him making this big statement
to like you move to a farm in Alabama
like yeah like move to Iowa and then say
you left Hollywood right no you're I
mean you're Stones Throw farmer still
commute for an audition right but
anyways he revealed that he and his wife
Nikky Reed packed up their things and
moved to a farm just outside of Los
Angeles with their two children he said
I loved what I did for a really long
time I don't miss any of it I love
making films and I just did it for so
long we had an amazing run so now he was
at the premiere of common ground which
is a documentary that focuses on the
need for sustainable and eco-friendly
farming and he shared some insight into
what life on the farm is like he said by
the way he didn't really leave Hollywood
if he's at a Premiere now I know it's a
premiere for like a farming documentary
Claudia he's having a hard time
extricating himself from the industry
but he's
trying a Premiere is a Premiere right
like Farmers don't really go to that
many premieres and do interviews no he
said when you see the way that nature
operates you find compassion oh my
literally bad literally B when he goes
for a walk when he goes for a walk he's
always like my like he goes in these
like really he'll like literally take a
walk and be like Steve Irwin yeah he
said it's a beautiful thing to see
what's happening with children to watch
them participate in the growing of their
food and the growing of their food and
the understanding of what food is and
where it comes from no there's something
about having kidss makes you question
where your food comes from by the way I
think that makes a lot of sense it
actually does make a lot of sense cuz
you start by first of all you're making
their food with breast milk but then
when you start giving them baby food a
lot of people choose to make their own
baby food which isn't even like a a
crunchy thing to do it's just like they
need food yeah I don't think it's let me
mash it up um and then you just start
thinking about the next thing you're
going to give them and you do look into
what it is because you've been so on top
of everything El you're not going to go
from mother's milk to process to
McDonald's I mean but Iana yeah yeah
yeah but it's so funny how like your kid
is like so clean and perfect and like
you are like shoving a crunch rep
Supreme down your throat in the back of
the car yeah I feel like that's
motherhood in a sense that is motherhood
and eventually the kids like get to it
depends like what age they're at and
people all feel differently but like
first when they're having just like baby
food whether it's ger or it's just it's
still not McDonald's unless you're going
to put the chicken nugget in a blender I
might you might you should I will
and then of course inevitably you're
like oh well you're going to all this
effort for the child like it makes you
think about your food differently it
just does of course of course but
anyways the environment theme
documentary serves as a followup to the
documentary kiss the ground he said I
started connecting the dots between what
you do for the planet and what you do
for yourself it's an evolution and a
lifelong Pursuit both him and Nikki are
executive producers on the project oh
wow so not only did he go to Premiere he
made a movie but he lefted Hollywood
yeah he's still in the movie making
industry but also a credit to their
homesteading ways Nikki had a home birth
now do you feel like these two have
enough money cumulatively to like not
work
anymore she's from Twilight a major
major franchise five huge movies she was
not a main character no no I maybe not
from that but he's from Vampire Diaries
yeah which is huge but I was actually
just thinking about this I feel like
everyone in Hollywood like when you go
all these people who go to award show
and everything like they're all like
they're not like the biggest stuff or a
million things but I feel like they all
live in like multi-million dollar homes
how so Nikki Reed's net worth is 12
million and then Ian summer holder's net
worth also says 12 million oh maybe
that's like their married net worth
yeah but then you know they're probably
working on the farm and they're doing
this documentary but I feel like a
documentary like this probably costs
more money than it earns if we're being
real no one's watching this I'm sorry
not even like someone who might be
interested in it like you no I'm not did
I say I was no but like this is not out
of the realm of your interest no it is I
don't want to watch a documentary about
Eco farming I want to watch the crown oh
she said what she said like I'm no even
ballerina Farm's not watching this no
she is no she's not she's like being a
queen competing well hopefully hopefully
apparently she's
competing which is even crazier I know
we were like debating all week what the
hell she was doing at the Mrs America
Pageant we thought she was like a former
winner we thought she was a judge we
thought she was a host turns out she's
literally a contestant um she had a baby
14 days ago which makes her like
deciding to enter into this pageant even
more psychotic um and she's obviously
gonna win yeah no if she doesn't win
it's a rigged yeah she is Mrs America I
know I feel like Nikki Reid like has
ballerina Farm on her vision board Fina
Fina yeah you know what actually I did
want to see like who that I follow
follows ballerina Farm that's such a
good question let me go out some people
out them as being what connoisseurs of
greatness
ballerinas ballerinas wow she's at 8
million followers I have 34 mutuals I
have 28
Stacey
Copo Emma
Roberts
Gadot Lauren Elizabeth wow there's
somebody here I need to unfollow I'll be
right back on that Craig
Conover oh there's someone you need to
unfollow just
one just one Khloe Fineman for best
thanl follows
her a lot of peeps justess James Decker
JJ D yeah no she's
extremely
inspirational I'm infinitely inspired so
she's probably going to see the
documentary perhaps cuz she has more
time in the day than anyone
else right that should be the new meme
like you have the same amount of hours
in the day as ballerina farm right not
Beyonce or Chris Jenner or Ryan CR crash
like they have a literal staff yeah do
you think Bina Farm has a nanny yeah
I've seen a more criticism of her that
she has a nanny maybe even more than one
Nanny she has eight kids yeah she's
running a business what's wrong with
having in like in like the mom you know
sphere what's wrong with having an an
nothing like digitally I guess they
would just say it to like take away from
the fact that she's raising eight kids
like it doesn't count if she has an
ananny oh it counts oh it counts yeah
okay so that's what Ian and Nikki are up
to farm life it is really crazy that
they got married when they're both
vampires I know and I feel like when
they got together there was something a
little bit nefarious about it so Nina DV
but the proof is in the pudding it's
giving not only is the proof in the
pudding but Nina doev she was kind of
like the loser in the situation like he
you know they we were together for a
while and everybody shipped them but she
ended up you know on top as well it took
a little while but she ended up in a
fabulous relationship fabulous really
really
fabulous yeah no Nikki and Ian they're
like
um Jason Al and Britney
Al it's true like this no even though I
don't think Ian's no no they're not
because I don't think Ian some some
older cheated on Nina there was
something there was something like not
entirely kosher no I think it was just
like he broke up with her I don't know
and they kept pitting nah and what's her
name against each other and eventually
they like took a picture together and
was like stop oh I don't think there was
nothing nefarious about the way they got
together that's why Britney and Jason Al
like no they like were home wrecking you
know yeah but like now they just have
this beautiful family and yeah so look
Nikki Reed shuts down rumors that that
she's feuding with Nina doev with a
powerful Instagram post this is 2017 so
it was like years and years of people
like putting these two against each
other I think a similar gelina no
no Brad Angie and Jen is similar to oh
actually no because did they cheat Brad
and Angie yeah yeah okay no no no and
now they've broken up so the proof was
not in the pudding so according to the
tabloids nah doev and Nikki Reid were
daggers for each other nah Dov was
jealous of Reed and summer holder's
marriage while Nikki re re Reed felt
threatened by her history with him so
like they literally were broken up then
and got
together yes except that like there
definitely is beef between Haley and
Selena I'm sure Selena hates haey she
looks at her marriage and hates her and
I am positive that haey hates Selena
Gomez for what she put her through how
could she not 100% but that would be
like in a few years if they are posting
like there's no be no but Jackie they
did remember they went to LACMA and they
took a photo and everyone was like oh my
God it's done and hay had just been on
call her daddy and said I have respect
right right so that was that but it
restarted so that would be like if n
that means they were lying that means
they were lying oh no or just like they
squashed it but then there was new
beef they tried to tell us there was no
beef and there was no I think they
squashed their beef and then eyelash
gate
Selena 2023 happened yeah yeah yeah
that's what I think and it hurt Hal even
more cuz she was like I thought we are
good okay maybe a similar okay maybe a
similar comparison here I'm gonna find
it is Robert
herc were Nina and Ian married no okay
oh you're right so it's not the
same but did Robert herc cheat with his
Dancing with the Stars partner or just
left his wife of like 50 years to go
have babies with I think that they were
like separated okay like it wasn't super
nefarious but it wasn't the best but
it's a proof as in the pudding
situation okay I know you I know you
hate Robert heric I know you do I do
hate nothing he does will ever be good
enough for you
never and like as long as you can own it
that's fine by me I just want to say I
don't like ha him for no reason like I
hate Sam Hunt for a reason like I hate
people for reasons I don't like that he
like was a really successful businessman
stayed with his wife forever and then he
got famous went on Dancing With the
Stars and left his wife for a younger
woman like to me that's somebody without
Scruples
okay like it's easy to be loyal to your
wife as you grow old together when
nobody knows who you are then you get a
little bit of attention
no okay are you ready for our fifth and
final story I am it's a little more
sports news that's relevant to this show
Alli raceman joins ESPN as their
gymnastics analyst in a new chapter her
career love in news that makes sense the
three time Olympic medalist is set to
join the network as an analyst on its
ncwa gymnastics broadcast people has
exclusively learned ESPN will make an
official announcement on Thursday
afternoon she will make her broadcasting
debut on Friday during a a meet between
LSU and Kentucky no I [__] love Ally
raceman more than life itself she's
probably my favorite female athlete I
don't know you know how I feel about
Serena Williams I wrote my college
dissertation on her nevertheless
um love Jewish Queen doing the most
she's been probably she's been quiet but
I'm sure she took wait who was it that
dated Colton Underwood Al raceman Miss
Allison raceman wow yeah I forgot about
that that's a major throwback Colton
Underwood has lived a hundred lives he
really has do you know what a clip I
just saw that I had completely forgotten
about when he was doing promo for The
Bachelor he did like this funny skit
with Billy Iker and he's like watch out
you become the first gay Bachelor
and uh Colton just like clenches his
butthole and like freaks out like it's
literally the most awkward clip and in
the Moment Like It didn't seem innocuous
it just seemed like he was like the
straight guy uncomfortable
like
now I totally forgot about that moment
that's really funny I'm sure also Ali
raceman like is getting her feet wet in
gymnastics broadcasting because of the
Summer Olympics coming up you know
she'll get all this practice on the NCAA
meets and then ready to narrate the
Olympics for us which is great for sure
I'm sure this is like a hop skip and a
jump away from the Olympics in terms of
like you know you can't broadcast the
Olympics if you've never broadcast
before yeah and it's good to get some
practice I'm sure she knows all about
practice I honestly feel like she's
following the footsteps like she'll have
a really similar broadcasting career as
Johnny Weir who's like the official
figure skating broadcaster for like
everything well in the past it's been
NASA leukin who's been like the
gymnastics correspondent with experience
I feel like she'll still be doing it but
there's a lot of networks and there's a
lot of broadcasting needs and gymnastics
is like the biggest sport in Summer
Olympics I think there can be more than
one I do think it's interesting like
these really young women who get so like
the gymnastics girls those five every
year they get so famous and I do think
it's really interesting to watch what
they do afterwards you know yeah like
sea Johnson totally went the influencer
route and I think she makes like so much
money and I think she's really happy and
fulfilled yeah and she has three kids
it's a perfect influencing such a great
job for like a mom it is so I love that
Simone biles is she still
competing I I don't know if she's going
I think she is going to the Olympics uh
I don't know is Simone
biles retired and then like Sunni Lee
like went to college and now she's like
a college
athlete yeah Simone biles is not retired
okay so we'll see what she does next
she's coming back from the
twisties excuse me you you remember in
the Olympics that she didn't compete oh
yeah they call that the twisties yeah
she said she had the twisties which it's
like when you just get like disoriented
and you it's a mental block of being
able to do the twists oh I like that
name yeah I can understand it yeah so
Ali racan is going Alli raceman is going
the broadcasting route love yeah I need
her to like reenter the spotlight we
need like more Jewish
leaders she's just an absolute Queen so
I'm excited a queen I'm excited for the
Olympics tury so am I that's going to
become like our new personality when the
time when is it summer4 summer summer
summer summer and it's in
Paris Paris how exciting yeah so that's
our show what kind of feels like a
Friday but it's not it's not no no it's
a day of THS benefits and perils the
hers J I hope everybody enjoyed the show
hopefully our YouTube thing like worked
out and you're watching this like Gorly
quickly if
not sorry to have gotten you excited but
it's like it's going to be one of those
things that like that's like my life's
work and like when I'm like dying I'm
like finally going to figure it out you
know totally and then I'm going to pass
it on to the next generation of
podcasters and I will be like a woman
who open doors for other women that's
you th% it's it will be you regardless
of how things go today with YouTube
thank you and thank you so much for
listening to the toast M Morning Show
where we deliver the past five stories
you need to know every Monday Friday on
YouTube so if you're watching us on
YouTube please feel fre to subscribe and
give this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
can be found so Spotify Stitch public
radio radio cast box all the places
listen podcast find us toast leave five
you about our beautiful standing and
kidly talented we are hope you guys have
an amazing day and we'll see you
tomorrow for for what jagy Friday
no
Friday you want to get into it even
though it's day of THS okay you're right
you're right you're right let's not
shoot let's not shoot our
right love you
bye